he's an American internet entrepreneur
and blogger his first company was part
of the dot-com era in New York he has a
net worth of 20 million dollars he's
Jason Calacanis and hear his top 10
rules for success things should be
different this way and I see the world
differently I wanted to get to this what
I want things to function the way I
think they should it's so hard to make
that actually happen that most people
never do the first step which is trying
you know and and that's ninety nine
percent of one percent like ninety-nine
percent of people everybody knows that
things should be better everybody's got
ideas of how to make things better I
mean ideas are very easy there a
commodity it's really not much value in
ideas really the person who says I'm
going to take that idea really try to
make it actually manifest itself into a
product or service that people can
consume and engage with and fall in love
with that's entrepreneurship that's the
difference I've always loved technology
and building things and building
products and 20 years into my career and
sure I don't need to work anymore I got
lucky on a couple of projects to make a
little bit of money and that's nice but
I love building teams I love building
products I love building brands
themselves so I love the act of creating
a brand like launch that means something
to people or inside calm where people
saying like you did like oh you didn't
gadget so for me I just love the act of
creating a brand and maybe hopefully
doing something innovative and I think
on my best day I'm able to do that and
on an average day maybe not so much the
expectation from where I came from and
listen I didn't come from like the slums
and you know Bangladesh or something so
I don't want to over emphasize it but
the expectation was I would be a cop so
I took the policeman's test and when I
was 17 or 18 years old with my little
brother Josh and he wound up going to
the police and I wound up going to Ford
him but at the time my dad had had his
restaurant repossessed by the federal
agents for not paying his taxes so they
came with shotguns that summer in 1988
and they close this place down and that
was the most traumatic moment of my life
it probably is the second most traumatic
moment my life after 911 and when
happened that changed everything about
me as a person like to see your dad have
his restaurant taken even got talking
about it now it's a 42 year old and I
just thought to myself wow you know that
he lost everything and he never
recovered from it that was like the end
of his entrepreneurial career and I said
to myself I'm never gonna fail a
business no matter what it takes I'll
win mm-hmm cuz I'm never gonna what the
feds take my place and he went a hundred
thousand dollars in debt you know in tax
evasion and all that stuff and it was
very scary but I had no money to go to
college so I had to work three jobs and
go to school at night at Fordham and I
learned a work ethic that I think made
me who I am today like I'm a very hard
worker I'm not the smartest kid in the
class you know but you know just in
terms of being clever and having hustle
I think my career proves like I'll get
it done no matter what you can't make
everything work as an entrepreneur
that's unrealistic and if everything you
do in your career is a home run that
means you're not swinging you hard
enough you're not swinging for the
fences you cannot win every time you
should be failing two out of three
things you do you know should fail and
if you're not if you're 16 everything
means you set the benchmark too low you
know I knew it was time to pivot when
google's results started going from 10
blue links to tim blue links with some
content at the top and a youtube video
and some news and all of a sudden I was
like wow you know it sort of was our
vision and sort of there already okay no
problem we'll just do something else and
you you look at what work you've done I
think the best pivots come out of what
lesson did you learn from your failure
what lessons did you learn from your
moderate success and i have to say
moderate success is much worse than
failure it's like the walking dead
that's the Kryptonite yeah if you have
moderate success if you can get your
business to exactly the amount of money
your payroll is your burn is and you
just go sideways that's when you're
truly screwed you know because you're
not you're gonna take your eyes off the
prize you've been like well I'm sort of
making in and then the business just
goes like this that's bad I don't
actually expand until you have something
that works well hmm so if you have
something that works well it'll be easy
to expand if it doesn't work it'll be
difficult to expand
I always like to do things when they're
easy so it'll be much easier to get it
done when you actually have a working
product so for example if somebody here
had a working product that did really
good message boards and we don't have
message boards of mahalo yet if they
came to me and said we have a hundred
thousand users it's working would you
like to use our technology I'd say sure
and maybe we'd buy it from them to do a
joint venture so we would be very open
to that kind of a joint venture if they
prove it it works if they haven't proven
it works it makes it difficult really
what define me as an entrepreneur was I
just never felt I could ever lose look I
had to win I could never let the
bastards take me down with they took my
dad down I had to fight and it put a
fight in me that was you know like not
human it was like superhuman fight like
a resiliency and a fire that I didn't
know I had and it served me very well
some people go to work every day to put
a roof you know over their family said
and to put food on the table and there
is an honor that and a respect I have
for those people obviously there's
nothing more noble than being able to
take care and provide for your family
but you could even do that with an
entrepreneurial spirit and so mark
pincus talks about everybody from our
figures from zynga talk about everybody
being the CEO of something in his
company you could be in a big company
and still have that entrepreneurial
spirit where you're thinking about how
to innovate and how to change the world
and put a dent in it and try to move the
human race forward you know and I think
that's really what entrepreneurship is
is that you you're relentless in your
pursuit of making something that didn't
exist before right you know trying to
make the world a little better trying to
make the experience a little better
looking at things and saying if that
gets if I was ten percent better or
twenty percent better or two hundred
percent better what would it look like
and then trying to take that vision and
make it reality I have a very open
policy to information so I explain every
single thing I know because what I've
learned about leadership is for more
information you share the more you
educate people of every single thing you
know the more they come back to you with
other ideas to increase your knowledge
base and the less stress there is on you
so for example
you know we use google analytics right
to to track how the site's going I made
every single person in the company go
through mandatory Google Analytics
training most people when they're
running website they don't give the
Google Analytics to anybody because they
want to have that proprietary
information knowing what's going on
keepers of the flame exactly and people
want to you know keep the data or you
know the salesperson and run the sales
organization wants to keep the list of
all the contacts and they you know only
certain sales people can see certain
verticals you know people develop
software to keep people in an
organization from getting to information
and you know I always found that very
bizarre share if you trust them enough
to hire them and work with them every
day they just give them every piece of
information you have let everybody share
it and discuss it and debated in a very
flat structure don't create a lot of
management and create discourse and I
make myself not only available to my
entire staff all the time I make myself
available to my enemies my detractors my
fans you're very transparent it's the
best way to run a business because all
you do is get ideas and and the work
that is usually the responsible the CEO
gets sent out to these you know hundreds
of brains and you know it's a it's
idiotic to think that you are smarter
than everybody in the world and
sometimes when you're in that CEO
position or the founder position you
start to think well I had the initial
vision I'm so smart but you know the
collective intelligence is always going
to trump individuals you know and so I
look back at the people in my life and
I'm just so blessed to have so many
people have been so loyal to me and
taught me so much and then also I've
gotten to be a loyal friend to them as
well and that's really like I think when
you look at your career always aspire
I'm not saying I have succeeded but
always aspire to be the best most loyal
person you can be to your friends and
develop those long-term meaningful
relationships it is the core of what's
valuable in life so you've done Silicon
Alley reporter and weblog saying yeah
Mahalo yeah when open angel for us
creating brands launch lunch you're a
writer in your own right sure is there
any separation or is that all just Jason
it's all what do you think that's all I
Jason you know
I used to fret over a little bit and
then I realized like I have a little
entrepreneurial a DD I get excited to
have enthusiasm but I'm not going to try
to bridle it and put it all into one
project if I want to do an event and I
want to write my email newsletter and I
want to host this week in startups and I
want to you know be the CEO of mahalo
pursue education and do apps and all
this stuff I'm going to do everything
and I look at you know one of the great
entrepreneurs over our time not Steve
Jobs jay-z and you know he is an amazing
entrepreneur he is an artist who's on
stage and he is probably the greatest
rapper alive today in my opinion he is
and Biggie Smalls was probably the best
that ever lived but rest in peace but
jay-z also you know ran a record label
and you know manages other people's
careers and a clothing line and this is
the southern I just think those rap
artists have and the people in the
hip-hop space have a very good view of
the world which is why not try
everything why not do a little bit of
everything and if some people think
you're doing too much that's that's on
them that's not I me and you know people
say oh well what are your investors in
this company think about you working on
this or they love the fact that I'm
diverse I love the fact that I get to
you know spend a couple of weeks in the
launch conference learn a lot and then
parlay that into my own day-to-day
experience as an entrepreneur and I just
love being involved in a lot of
different things so I I don't fret over
it too much anymore thank you so much
for watching i made this video because
Matthew Hendricks asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Jason
Calacanis is top ten rules meant the
most to you leave it in the comments I'm
going to join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching between to
believe and I'll see you soon